hello there you're watching the press
preview our first look at what's on the
front pages
as they arrive over the next half an
hour we're going to be talking about the
headlines with the new statesman's
political editor
stephen bush and the spectators
economics correspondent kate andrews so
good to see you both good evening
hi anna so let's take a look then what's
making the front pages and the metro
reports that according to latest figures
almost a thousand covered 19 jabs per
minute
are now being administered the eye has
word of forthcoming vaccines
aimed at better tackling new variants of
the virus
that news comes as the vaccine's
minister nadine zahawi
writes in the daily telegraph insisting
the oxford astrazeneca jab
is safe to use against the strains
currently present in the uk
the daily mail suggests that illegal
immigrants will be granted an amnesty to
get vaccinated
the mirror speaks to amy bestwick who
was caught up in the dunblane school
shooting 25 years ago and is now
expecting
her first child the express launches a
campaign which it says aims to
save the environment and boost the
country's economy
the star pitches the extreme winter
conditions thanks to
storm darcy and the financial times
reports on the increasing cost of
liability insurance
for company directors
so stephen bush and kate andrews uh here
with me to take us through some of those
headlines
once again stephen a lot of coronavirus
stories around
particularly focusing on the vaccination
program
the metro leads with the stat that the
vaccine minister
repeated today 1 000 jabs a minute
it's quite an impressive role at this
isn't it
yeah yeah the vaccine rollout has gone
uh
very well every week uh successfully
vaccinating more people of course we
would expect that to
increase for uh two very important
reasons the first is that
as more vaccines are developed by the
various companies and universities
researching them we have more available
and the second is is that as we go
through the groups that are most at risk
it becomes
easier to do it quicker um we are
mostly now getting to the end of people
who perhaps need mobility assistance
things which make it slightly
longer and we're starting to enter
towards the stage in which
it becomes much much quicker at every
and so it's a really positive story all
round
that's right and also on the metro's
front page they also
quote the latest statistics suggesting
that cases
are falling by 25 percent in a week they
say that deaths
are down a third so so there is good
news here
here kate isn't there i mean obviously
there are challenges in this rollout as
well
uh because as the vaccine minister was
saying today
you've not only got the the next group
of vulnerable groups taking us up to
group 9 which is the over 50s but also
at the same time you've got to
administer second doses as well
given that we've been so far mostly
running out first doses
no there certainly are challenges ahead
and given the full uk track record on
handling cover 19 so far i don't think
anybody wants to count their chickens
but there's no denying that the the
rollout of the program so far has been a
a huge success it would be interesting
to see the tactics that are used to get
people back for their
second jabs uh whether or not that
proves slightly more difficult
than the first round and but the
timeline here is spectacular the
spectator has a
a vaccine tracker on its website and at
the moment if we continue at this pace
it's projected that
we'll hit the four most vulnerable
groups and have offered everybody
uh their first jab and potentially even
by the end of this week so a few days
ahead
of schedule um and if we can keep this
up we're looking going into the spring
with those who are really vulnerable
from this virus because of pre-existing
conditions or because of their age
uh having higher levels of protection
the ons publishes antibody survey this
week and that was fascinating as well
roughly 25
of the over 80s are now testing positive
for antibodies in england and
that used to be because of cases that
was a really sad statistic but now we're
finally seeing that vaccine factor
come into play and it is uh as stephen
points out and as you point out anna
really good news
that's right but let's move on to the
front of the eye now because
they're talking about new jabs being
developed to
deal with virus variants and and
that has thrown up some news today that
the
the prospect of our existing vaccines
their ability to deal with some of the
variants so stephen
talk us through what happened today
right so
um we're starting to see the first test
not only of its effectiveness at
reducing infections here but again some
of the new variants
we've seen emerging both here and
elsewhere which the language is most
worrying
the medical community own is the variant
that uh started in south africa
now variants can happen any time but
they're they're most likely to happen in
patients who have weakened immune
systems
and because of the ongoing legacy of the
hiv aids epidemic around the world which
has been particularly acute in
sub-saharan africa
you have a larger number of people who
are immunocompromised
um so what we're starting to see isn't
the oxford vaccine works
very well against the variants we mostly
have here less well against new variants
and because
many scientists believe it's quite
likely that we will move to a situation
where we're having
uh annual coronavirus vaccines in a
similar way to we have annual flu
vaccines and of course
not ev every year the flu vaccine
doesn't necessarily work as well as it
does in some years
uh as others so it's a mixed story
um but in many ways of course beyond
some of the wildest dreams people had
you know even
uh a couple of months ago where many in
government still feared
we would never have a vaccine well yes
and this study which i think we'll get
more details of tomorrow
kate uh suggests that the oxford vaccine
does isn't very effective against people
with mild um
outbreaks of the disease at the the
group the team
is confident that it will work against
more serious uh disease but in the
meantime there's also
a kind of booster jab being developed
already that they hope will be
ready as early as the autumn to deal
with
with this variant and potentially other
variants
as well yes we've had really mixed news
on
vaccines this week when it comes to
their efficacy uh
i should say last week now a pre-print
in the lancet showed that the oxford
vaccine
overall was actually roughly six
percentage points more
effective than we originally thought it
does seem to be protecting from severe
cases hospitalizations and deaths
we also had news around the johnson and
johnson vaccine the novovax vaccine
that while they weren't as effective
against the south african strain they
were still preventing against
hospitalizations and deaths so i suspect
we're going to get
more news out and if we also look at the
front of the daily telegraph you
again have ministers saying you know we
need to have faith in the evidence so
far
looks pretty good that when it comes to
the metrics we care
most about and that's preventing people
from going into hospital
preventing people from dying from this
disease these vaccines
are still holding up and i think the
difficult thing is that
this is all a working process a lot of
these things haven't been peer reviewed
yet
and so there's still a lot of
outstanding questions and it really
didn't help this week that you had
senior figures in the european union
making claims about the oxford vaccine
that i think
were uncomfortably close sometimes to
misinformation or disinformation
and just promoting things about it not
working in the
over 65s that they didn't seem to have
very much evidence for
um so you have a lot of mixed language
out there about these vaccines and
that's what
ministers are trying to set the record
straight on in the telegraph today
yeah that's right they've got an
interview haven't they with nadine
savari there in
the telegraph and but stephen to what
extent will there be pressure on the
government
now to make sure that the the cases of
the south african
variant in this country um obviously far
far
fewer than other um the original either
the original strain or the uk variant
but those cases that are known about are
really clamped down on and
also that we protect against any new
cases coming in
well yeah it does of course increase the
political pressure uh to have the
airbase an effective system to test
trace but crucially to
isolate new cases we actually have a
very good system now to
to test and trace provided the case load
is low enough the problem is we don't
have any particular
system to get people to stay in one
place once they have
been given that positive test and if you
don't have that ability to isolate
then really all your test and trace
system allows you to do is go yep we've
got a problem here
so we'll increase the pressure not only
to prevent the flow of new variants into
the country but also to tackle them
within it um but of course it is a much
much
better problem to have than the one that
we faced at the start of
of 2020. that's right and and and kate
also
a reminder that we're getting
information all the time about
uh various changes to the virus but also
more information about the effectiveness
of various vaccines as well
and in the meantime the politicians are
having to work out
at what stage you release the
restrictions we've been
living under we're going to get more
details from the prime minister later
this month but there's a there's a lot
of different data to be dealing with
that's a really important point anna a
lot of these studies and trials that
we're reporting on
and some sometimes don't have very many
people in the trials a few thousand and
you need bigger trials to
really come up with conclusive
information so when we're talking about
efficacy rights when we're talking about
metrics around hospitalization and death
this data does change it does update it
can become more positive or negative and
you know we're all just trying to keep
up with the information that we do have
ministers uh really do not want to
commit to when
lockdown is going to be lifting they
have given that date of march 8th when
they hope that perhaps schools can start
reopening
and we are going to hear more from the
prime minister very soon about his road
map out of lockdown
but they really don't want to over
promise i think there's a strong feeling
that the government has over promised
far too often in the past and
under-delivered
they would prefer i think to surprise
people this time around the difficulty
of course
um is that people have been facing you
know weeks sometimes months depending on
where you are of restrictions now
and not knowing the end date to that can
be quite grueling
that said it does still appear
compliance is very high but as steven
mentioned the one area of compliance
that we know
people struggle with is to not go
outside to not leave their home when
they have symptoms that is one of the
most important things to do if you have
symptoms you need to stay at home and
and something we still really haven't
tackled in terms of proper support
during this crisis
and stephen what are you picking up um
from
your dealings with various ministers and
government uh insiders about how
the prime minister is minded to deal
with restrictions obviously there's
pressure from some back benches to lift
restrictions sooner others are more
cautious
what's your feeling about what line he
might take
well obviously the prime minister is is
not someone who is instinctively pro
this kind of stuff
um but the the real debate still is is
ultimately over cost right
a number of bit the original support
packages built around
essentially rent and salaries and at
some point the fixed costs become
acute so that's one of the pressure
points at what point do you open up to
avoid having to have further
subsidy and the other is actually just
about the logistics and shape of
our country unlike australia we are a
country which uh
has a much closer trading relationship
in terms of food with our nearest
neighbor
and we do have an open land border we
shouldn't forget with
with uh with um with ireland so
some of the issues are logistical some
of the issues are about subsidy
but there is a real willingness of
course partly not to be outflanked
politically
by the labor party who have been banging
drama and quarantine but also to keep on
side
the parliamentary party which um has a
number of people who do not like these
restrictions
and would like them to end sooner rather
than later indeed and i think we'll hear
more details on the 22nd isn't it
february so um that'll be a day to watch
uh we're going to take a break plenty
more coming up including joe biden
brings back the so-called presidential
fireside chat uh we don't have a fire
but we will have some chat
after the break welcome back you're
watching the press preview with me
tonight stephen bush and kate andrews
and kate we're taking a look at the
front of the financial times next it's
the second story on that front page
a tick tock plans e-commerce push in
threat to u.s social media giants so
talk us through this one
yes it was just a few months ago that
president donald trump was trying
to ban the app from being further
downloaded in the united states
which tick-tops tick-tock stopped
through the courts at the time
and only a few months later you have a
very different story on the front of the
ft
in which their report they report are
planning an aggressive expansion into
e-commerce in the united states
and they're going to return to almost an
old-school kind of affiliate marketing
in which
people are going to be able to uh
hopefully
they hope buy products straight off of
people um promoting them
on the tick tock site um almost as if
you were to have television marketing
but on a ticktop platform instead
and so i think it's interesting in terms
of how tiktok plans to compete with
silicon valley it's interesting about
the marketing tactics they'll use but i
find the story most interesting
because um it would really seem that in
a few months time
and this uh china-based app thinks that
it can have a lot more influence in the
us under president trump of course they
thought they might be getting banned
so it speaks to that geopolitical
dynamic that is one that joe biden is
going to have to address
yeah really interesting have either have
you got a tick tock account do you make
little videos of dancing or
um well i don't but the new statesman
does have an official one which i have
occasionally
done what the younger members of staff
tell me is a a meme
on there excellent i like thinking the
tick tock star
dance i've just given you a perfect
opportunity to plug your
your tick tock site there um and stephen
let's take a look at the front of the
daily telegraph
biden reintroduces fdr's fireside chat
yep so this is a way that uh franklin
roosevelt
during the great depression used to talk
and then during second world war
used to every week address the nation
through his semi-informal
far side and joe biden plans to do the
same and you can see the argument for
doing this
both because we're in a scary time of
crisis i think many of us actually do
appreciate the daily messages from the
government it seems that we now get
but also uh the other reason why it's
quite significant and i think astute
move is one of the ways that biden is
marketing and presenting himself is a
return to normality
calmness you know where the president's
going to be and not kind of going over
what has he just tweeted and it's
another way that it physically embodies
that change
um from this sort of chaotic era of
donald trump to what joe biden wants to
present as the era of
normality uh whatever that may mean
under joe biden
do you think that's right kate i mean do
you think this will work well with the
american public
yeah i think it will for the reasons
that stephen lays out especially during
such difficult times i think it's
reassuring to hear from the people
who are leading the country and who are
in charge
uh and it is a bit of a return to
normality i'm not sure that the stories
that are featured in the moments that
the president has are
necessarily going to you know sway those
who dislike him or didn't vote for him
that he is exactly who they need to be
in charge but it's just a bit of a
reminder about
you know that he is a president for all
americans not just those who voted for
him
okay stephen and kate we are out of time
but i'm pleased to say you'll be back at
11 30. so i shall see you then and thank
you for now
you